Rollins professor at the Rollins School of
Public Health based there in Atlanta, Georgia
at Emory University.
He is a member of the National Academy of
Science Committee on Applied and Theoretical
Aspects of Statistics.
And his research involves the development
of statistical methods for geographic data,
including applications in environmental justice,
epidemiology, disease surveillance, spatial
cluster detection, conservation biology, and
disease ecology.
His research has appeared in numerous biostatistical,
statistical, environmental health, and ecology
journals as well as he's authored a textbook
entitled Applied Spatial Statistics for Public
Health Data.
And so prior to us getting Dr. Waller underway,
I'd like to invite you all to submit any questions
that you have for Dr. Waller through the GoToWebinar
question submission system, which is located
in the little console there off to, probably,
the right of your screen.
And you can do that, and then we'll save some
time at the end where I'll read those questions
off to Dr. Waller.
So without further ado, Dr. Waller, the stage
is yours.
Great.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here, and I'd like to
offer my own wishes for a happy St. Patrick's
Day.
I hope you're are all doing very well in your
office basketball pools because, as data scientists,
you should be.
Today we will be talking about-- well, that's
what I look like.
And we'll be talking about multiple testing,
bias, confounding, and missing data-- or as
a subtitle, what could go horribly wrong with
my analysis?
I'm going to give a little insight on thinking
about team data science and team science and
the data science setting with a little bit
of background to distinguish between observational
experimental data and prediction versus estimation.
To put this in context, I've been watching
these webinars over the last several weeks
to get a sense of the kinds of topics, and
we have a lot of people with a lot of different
interests.
So I want to set some context.
We'll talk about multiple testing, bias, confounding,
missing data.
I'll try to give an example for each and sources
for additional information and then wrap it
up coming back to team data science.
So data science is often presented as requiring
skills from computer science, statistics,
or an application or subject matter area,
which often leads to the battle of the Venn
diagrams.
This is just one example here and a couple
of postings where people have looked at this,
but you can see the three scopes.
We've got this pinkish color, hacking skills
or computer science.
And we've got math and statistical knowledge.
And then we've got the substance area.
And in a school of public health, for me,
it's a lot of health-related research.
Data science is, kind of, that sweet spot
in the middle.
We could have more than three directions.
One of them has a seven-set Venn diagram,
which I'd never seen before, so I thought
I'd share that with you too.
The webinar series-- I really appreciate the
BD2K program putting this on because it has
provided and continues to provide a forum
for introduction across these elements.
So if you go to data science seminars within
your own
discipline, you tend to hear people with similar
perspectives talking.
And, I think, really, where the growth is
is this cross-talk.
So I've really learned a lot from the webinars
and hope you're enjoying them as well.
In computer science, there have been webinars
on hardware-- just the basic setup of doing
big data.
Also algorithms and statistics, we've got
several on concepts, techniques, Bayesian
analysis and so on.
I think it's the intersection of all these
were the unique and emerging issues come up.
And today what I'm talking about are trying
to draw some statistical concepts from observational
studies, often from epidemiology-- then how
these may scale up or how they may need to
be revised in a big data setting.
So we'll talk about definitions, examples,
and the scaling issue primarily.
I think each and every one of these is wide
open for additional work, so I'm not stating
that these are problems of a statistical nature
and dropping the microphone, but, instead,
we want to have an invitation for the interdisciplinary
work and really work those intersections in
the Venn diagram.
Team data science-- there's a lot of interesting
discussions going on at conferences and in
publications on the intersection between these
areas.
And one thing that I've heard recently is
the discussion of whether a team of data scientists
should consist of several people who are identical
or several people with complementary skills.
I tend to favor the idea of the heterogeneous
team because it brings different expertise
and experience, also different problem solving
intuition.
That's a big deal to me.
Are people understanding?
How do they approach a problem?
What do they think the cool part of it is?
If you have different people on the team looking
at that from different aspects, I think you
get much more creative, analytic, and interpretation
perspectives in your analysis.
Interdisciplinary team science can be very
tricky if you want to go all the way to transdisciplinary
collaborations.
I tell my students and colleagues that I think
it's a lot like international travel when
you work interdisciplinary setting.
The language is different.
The social norms are different.
What the cool journals are is different.
How money counts, what you should write into
a grant-- that all needs to be negotiated.
It's also a lot like a middle school dance
where you've got multiple groups who are interested
and they know they want to interact with each
other but they're not quite sure how to do
that yet.
And so they tend to cover up the insecurity
with a lot of teasing.
And we see that in the publications, too,
of-- they're trying to establish their own
discipline as the key discipline in here.
I also, recently-- I don't have this on the
slide-- heard a definition that disciplinary
work is like an apple.
Disciplinary collaboration's like a fruit
basket.
Interdisciplinary works like a fruit salad.
And transdisciplinary work is like a smoothie.
So how to data impact science?
That's our question.
Our goal and big data to knowledge is to take
data, extract information from it and develop
knowledge.
So I want to frame this in terms of questions,
analytic tools, and answers.
And this is something we present in class
a lot-- the geographic information systems
class I start with.
And I can't take credit for this.
John Richardson, who was a toxicologist at
the EPA Region 4 office here in Atlanta once
said, it's this simple.
And he drew this picture.
And I thought it was brilliant, and I really
like this.
So we start in the upper left.
There's some question we want to answer.
I know in a lot of unstructured data mining
there's a lot of talk about hypothesis-free
analysis, but I don't think we go in completely
blind.
I think there are things we're interested
in finding out.
So they may be hard to articulate, but this
first step is articulating what you're looking
for, what kinds of things you're looking for.
And before running anything or before extracting
data or looking for the data, I think it's
important to spend some time thinking about
what data what you really need to answer that
question completely.
I do a lot of environmental health analysis.
So if I were interested in what's the impact
of exposure to drinking water near a hazardous
waste site on childhood leukemia rates, I
might want to know where every child lives
at what age, how much water they drink, does
their house require this?
I could go through a list of all the stuff
I'd love to get that I probably wouldn't be
able to.
But that list is a helpful mental checklist
when you take the next step, and say what
data are available?
We have a wide variety of data types available
to us now.
So we can get all sorts of things, but we
rarely get everything we want.
And we often get proxies for things we want.
Like, I may not know which child is drinking
from which water system, but I know where
they live, and I know where the hazardous
waste site is.
And I also may be able to find out that that
address is listed on the county water or public
water bill.
So I know they're getting water to the house,
but I don't know exactly what's going inside.
So it tells me something but not everything.
So on the lower, right-hand side, I get the
data I can get and the methods I have available.
I do answer some questions as I move up to
the upper right.
There are questions I can answer with my data
and my methods.
And, probably, the most important step here
is to go back to the beginning and see how
close the question I answered is to the question
I want to answer.
And I've presented this to many different
classes.
And one of the most interesting questions
I got was a student asking me, well, how do
you know when you're done?
And my answer was, well, I've been doing this
for 25, 30 years.
And, so far, we've never finished any of those.
You get around once, and you think about what
the next step is.
So you keep refining and getting closer and
closer pushing those two together.
But I don't know that it's ever complete.
This is just the research cycle and the way
I think we want to think about our data analysis.
So I also want to go into this pointing out
that our perspective as an individual data
scientist can impact what we see in the data.
Data science can reveal new things.
So we may have some really cool visualizations
or we hook together data that haven't been
together.
But we also have to be open to seeing the
patterns or the results that come out.
So we can link and process, wrangle, and munge
our data, but what does it really mean?
So I'm going to give a data science example
from 1854.
During the cholera outbreak in London-- this
was before the germ theory of disease was
well-established, so there were the miasma
people who thought it was in the air.
You could smell how bad it was in the summer,
and that's when it broke out-- versus contagion
ideas.
The miasmist theory at the time was that there
was bad air in the storm sewer system.
It was coming out through the drain holes.
And then, as many of you may be familiar with
John Snow's work, he was thinking that it
was the water from the water pumps.
So this is big data circa 1854.
This is a chart in a book referenced on the
right, Cartographies of Disease, of the cholera
outbreak in 1854 presented to the London Board
of Health.
And I'm not sure if you can see my cursor,
but this big, curved spike on the bottom is
the number of cases of cholera along with
diarrheal disease.
Those who follow each other carefully.
Everything in the background are meteorological
things, like barometric pressure and rainfall
and temperature and humidity.
And they were doing, on this chart, a lot
of what we try to do on the computer now--
is try to line up what's the magic signal
that starts off the outbreak.
So some of the things we're doing-- even though
it feels very modern, this sort of scientific
inquisitiveness with when you're presented
with lots of data from lots of sources-- has
been around for a while.
Of course, the big news in 1854 was Dr. John
Snow, an anesthesiologist who mapped the cholera
deaths in a neighborhood.
And I apologize in advance.
This slide has sound that was attached to
it by Carol Gotway, my co-author on our book,
and I haven't been able to figure out how
to get it out.
But the way the story generally goes is Snow
maps the cases in this particular neighborhood
in London.
He looks at that map.
He sees the concentration of the deaths around
a particular water pump on Broad Street, and
says, eureka!
That must be to cause.
Snow led an effort with others with the London
Board of Health to remove the handle of that
particular water pump.
So the short version of this story is Snow
did phenomenal work, and reading some of his
papers is highly recommended.
But this has been, kind of, compressed into
a fairy tale.
So this is a travel log for London saying,
"In 1854 Londoners were dropping like flies
from cholera until Dr. Snow figured out that
the bacteria were in the water."
He turned the pump off, saved countless lives.
And now, there's the John Snow pub nearby.
So that's good information.
But it does compress a lot of work that was
going on and a lot of controversy.
So we look at this visualization of the map.
John Snow's map's often presented as-- good
grief, if you just map the data, look at what
you can find.
And so it looks like a real triumph of 1854
data science and visualization.
But if you look carefully, the maps of the
miasmists looked exactly like Dr. Snow's.
And if you think about where the drain holes
are, they're right by the water pumps, 'cause
if your pump leaks, you'd like to have it
drain out.
So the maps look the same.
And, in fact, one of the leaders of the London
Board of Health had the following response
to Snow's 1854 analysis.
And he says, "This certainly looks more like
the effect of that atmospheric cause--" or
miasma-- "than any other.
If it were in the water, why wouldn't the
cholera have prevailed equally everywhere
where" people were drinking the water?
So we've got two different groups of people
looking at the same data, the same visualizations,
and they come to a different conclusion.
Now history supports Snow's conclusion, and
we see that as a triumph.
But it wasn't as if he slammed the map down
on the table and everybody saw the truth.
So that's a nice story.
What does this mean for us?
A lot of data-- there's been a lot of data
science breakthroughs in managing, linking,
processing, and visualizing distributed data.
But you could think about what would someone
like John Snow, an 1850s data scientist, do
with modern computing?
Like, if he had a geographic information system
or Google or social media, well, you might
be thinking he would be something like Google
Flu Trends.
Google Flu Trends' prediction goal was to
try to beat the CDC's projection of number
of influenza-like illnesses over a week.
These were reported weekly.
And they were doing it for a while.
They were about two weeks ahead of the CDC
release numbers.
These are no longer published on a regular
basis, although you can still get them.
So what happened is in February of 2013, the
Google Flu Trends was tweaking its algorithm--
or, actually, a month before that-- and started
to overpredict.
And in a particular week in February, they
predicted twice as many cases as actually
showed up.
So there's a very nice summary of this.
It's a short article on science by Lazer et
al-"The Parable of Google Flu."
And I spelled flu incorrectly, or it was auto-corrected.
So that's, I, guess another bit of big data
for you.
The way Google Flu Trends works-- it's based
correlated searches.
And so you're looking for correlations between
the kind of searches that happen that correspond
to the beginning or intensification of flu
outbreaks and things like high school basketball.
Searches for high school basketball score
will start at the beginning of the winter
about the same time the flu starts.
So it's not a causal connection, but it does
have strong predictive power.
And this has been one of the big successes
of Google and other data science development
areas.
Now that the Flu Trends algorithm was proprietary
and consistently tweaked, and so it's hard
to say that it was wrong all along.
That's not true.
It did very well.
And I'll show you one of the plots from the
Lazer paper on the
next slide.
And the authors don't discount the impact
of big data.
What they do discount is-- or point out--
that it offers an example of big data hubris.
Or we ignore everything we know about flu,
and just go with the data.
So this avoids the subject matter expertise
part of the Venn diagram and starts to wander,
maybe, not the part labeled danger zone, but
it starts to get away from as good a job as
we could do.
So this example, to me, is an example against
the idea of totally hypothesis-free science.
And I'm sure those people will debate me on
that.
And I think we need to worry about hypothesis
and past knowledges that we know.
I don't know that we have to identify a testable
hypothesis for everything we do, but we certainly
need to be documenting what we're after and
how we plan to find it.
This is the figure showing the estimates.
And what you see in the top plot is the percent
of influenza-like illnesses.
And the bottom is just the error between the
two, showing the noise around zero, and what
you see is starting after.
After July 2011, it starts to deviate some
more and into '13.
So with things like that, if we find a mistake,
it's not so much pointing out a mistake and
saying that it's wrong.
It's what could we do better with this?
So there's several quotes about learning from
mistakes.
You know, anyone who's never made a mistake
has never learned anything new.
Each mistake should teach us something.
And one of my recent favorites is always make
new mistakes.
It's-- you should learn from the mistakes
you make, but don't be afraid to try new things.
And so how do we expand data science without
reinventing the wheel regarding data challenges?
Some of that is knowledge and summaries of
these.
So in order to avoid mistakes in data science
as we expand, we should carry an appreciation
for data-based stumbling blocks that have
been established in the past and explore how
these manifest at scale and keep an eye out
for new sorts of challenges that may not have
been an issue in older-size datasets but would
be now.
So I'm going to review four data analysis
issues that remain relevant for big data but
also need to be customized and refined in
the big data context.
There's a couple of important contrasts I
want to mention too.
The first is observational versus experimental
data.
And this is where you're taking data that
you are seeing versus data that comes from
a designed experiment.
There was a period of time where the literature
referred to this as found data.
Working in geographic information systems,
we do this a lot.
We'll take the census data.
I don't want to map the census regions because
they've already done that.
I don't need to re-establish the census data,
but I want to link it to new data.
And a message I tend to give my students is
the data always looks greener if you didn't
collect them.
I think we
think that about social media data.
If you think about electronic medical records,
they include a lot of information, but some
of it may be opinion.
Some of it may not be as good as it sounds.
So as we grab the observational data to make
decisions, one question is does design matter?
Should we be hoping for an experiment or link
this to it?
Does it even matter?
I think I gave a big data talk once where
my title was Design is Dead, Long Live Design.
And my argument was we needed to come up with
new types of design to understand the sorts
of studies we were doing.
And that doesn't mean not to take use of the
big data, but it's to try to figure out how
to make the best use of big data.
So some questions-- do data have to come from
a design to be useful?
I don't think that's necessarily the case,
but I think you can gain things from a design.
And does data quality matter if I can get
a lot of data?
This is another big argument.
If I'd like independent observations, that'd
be great.
But I could take a whole lot of correlated
ones and, maybe, get the same information.
So what do you lose in observational data?
At a smaller scale, this is something epidemiologists
have been concerned with for a long time.
One design data about-- I thought this was
a really nice example that Xiao-Li Meng from
Harvard.
has put together.
And he proposes an interesting thought experiment.
Now this is in a discussion-- the reference
is on the bottom-- of a paper by Keiding and
Louis on "The Perils and Pitfalls of Self-selected
Entry into Epidemiological Studies and Surveys--"
the idea of using web forms, web recruitment,
to define your control base and so on.
And it raises a lot of question.
And there are many pages of discussion after.
So if that's an area you're interested in,
I think there's a lot of good information
in the article and the discussion.
But Xiao-Li points out this example.
Suppose we're interested in estimating the
average income in the United States, and we
had two choices of data sets.
One was 100 individuals selected in a simple
random sample.
So every individual in the United States is
equally likely to be selected and would participate.
Or we could get data from 50 million individuals,
but it's not as clean data that there's a
correlation between their income, which we're
interested in, and the probability of being
selected.
It's not a big correlation.
And he was setting an example of 0.05.
So what we're saying is suppose income was
slightly correlated with the probability of
completing a web survey about your income,
and then you want to get the estimate.
Well, 50 million in a hundred seems like,
wow, that's so big.
That must be good enough.
And Meng does some algebra.
I'm not going to show you.
But it's in the discussion that there's actually
more information in the small sample.
You'd need about 62 million to get the same
amount of information.
So in a big
data setting, we do get a lot more.
But I think there's a lot of interesting calculations
like this one to be done to talk about the
value and quantity of information contained
in data like that.
Also in design versus experiment, design experiments
allow one to control outside variables-- things
like temperature or genetic strain or precipitation--
that could have an impact on your outcome,
but they're not your primary interest.
And in studying flu, say, if we only took
observations in the summer, we would miss
things like the peak that generally happens
in the winter, associations with travel periods
and the times when school starts.
Design can help remove things, but we also
don't want to design our way around important
contributors.
So we have observational versus experimental
data.
We'll be talking mostly about observational.
The second contrast is prediction versus estimation.
I'm not going to make a contrast in my conclusions,
but I do want to point out these are different
issues, and we'll bring up both.
A lot of this discussion hinges on a paper
in 2001 on the two cultures in statistical
modeling that I think is one of the things
that feeds into data science.
The basic idea is if we have input, these
might be predictors.
They go into a box.
Something happens in that box, and we observe
some output.
The two cultures differ in what we're interested
in.
The prediction group is-- given me a new x,
can I predict y really well?
And I don't really care what happens in the
box.
I just want to be able to predict the outcome
well.
This information side, or estimation side,
is can I define the associations between x
and y and try to figure out what's happening
inside the box?
That may be just measures of associations,
like regressions and logistic regressions,
or it may well be something like more advanced
machine learning, deep learning, or a causal
inference.
So the distinction between the two is what
do you care to find out?
In epidemiology, there's a little bit of both.
We do want to predict how many flu cases there
are, because one, it can tell us how to set
up a prevention scheme.
If we know the types of strains, it can help
us plan for vaccinations.
But we're also-- there's a medical interest
in what causes things to spread.
And we're interested in what happens inside
the box too because if we predict well, I'd
like to know what's in the box so I could
change the outcome.
So what can get in the way of doing either
prediction or estimation?
How do we get the most out of big data?
Well, with respect to prediction-- again,
in Google Flu Trends, it's, like, we didn't
really care how basketball scores were associated
with flu, but we found out they helped us
predict better.
So that's a good thing.
With estimation, what can get in the way is
what makes our estimates wrong.
And then, if they're biased, is bias
always a bad thing?
So I'll come back to that in a minute.
These are the four issues we're going to be
talking about in this context of big data
and data science-- multiple testing, bias,
confounding, and missing and mismeasured data.
So multiple testing-- and statistical hypothesis
testing's been a mainstay for small data analysis
for decades.
Now there's been a lot written about it.
It certainly has-- there are some legitimate
concerns about turning all of your results
down into a yes or no answer.
But it's still out there.
The P-value reports is certainly something
to discuss, but you will see a lot of publications
based on that.
So in a statistical hypothesis testing setting,
you reject the null hypothesis at some level
of statistical significance, and typically,
this is 0.05.
And there's probably a lot of talks about
why 5% is there.
So this means for each test there's a 5% chance
of rejecting the null hypothesis when the
null hypothesis is actually true.
So it's a false positive result.
Well, it's 5% for each test.
But if you're doing a lot of tests, what does
this mean?
So when we're testing a lot of hypotheses--
and these might be checking associations between
several outcomes or several variables-- you
might think of a gene expression microarray,
lots and lots of observations.
If the tests were independent of one another,
then you would expect one in 20 to yield a
false positive result at this 0.05 level.
But what if you're testing 200,000 genes?
The magnitude of the problem-- there's a lot
of highly technical statistical calculations
you can do on this to get exactly what it
is, but-- especially if you've got correlation
and not independence.
But the problem remains how you scale this
up.
So what do you do?
Some potential solutions-- and some of which
have been around for a long time-- there's
Bonferroni adjustment.
If you have k independent tests, you just
adjust the significance level of each of the
tests by dividing by k, so the overall probability
of finding any false positives is 5%.
So it's a very conservative adjustment.
And it doesn't really scale well.
So if I want to split up my 0.05 across 200,000
tests, I'm talking about a P-value for significance
of 0.00000025. 0 And that's not particularly
meaningful.
You think about how much data you would have
to collect to have that kind of precision
out in the tails to be sure that that's what
your probability was.
Putting these things together usually gives
a family-wise probability of any false discoveries.
The probability that the number of false discoveries
is bigger than zero.
And that's served pretty well.
There's a lot of literature on multiple comparisons.
My own father wrote his dissertation on multiple
comparison issues, and there's a SAS procedure
with a Waller option using his technique.
But their scalability is a real problem here.
In 1995, and refined in 2000, Benjamini and
Hochberg introduced a concept called the False
Discovery Rate,
rather than the probability of false discoveries.
Now we often think of rates and probabilities
as similar, but there is a key distinction
here that they were making-- that false discovery
rate's not the probability of any false discovery.
It's the expected fraction of discoveries
you make, or any cutoff, that are false.
So this is different than what the Bonferroni
family-wise is doing, which is the probability
of having any false discoveries being bigger
than zero is 0.05.
So Benjamini and Hochberg are saying, we think
it would be worse to have four false discoveries
out of 10 than having 20 out of 100, where
that'd be one fifth.
So it's the rate of out of how many you detect,
what fraction do you think are false?
And this is fundamentally a different way
of thinking about it but one that scales much,
much better.
And so there's been widespread use of the
false discovery rate, especially in the genetics
and genomics literature.
And there's a lot of resources for exactly
how to calculate the false discovery rate.
I'm not going to talk about those here today,
so we can talk about the other topics.
But it's an excellent illustration of how
an inferential idea-things like false discoveries
and type I error rates-- needed to be rethought
to scale to the big data setting.
So we had an adequate solution at small scale,
but it didn't extend.
So addressing the issue required backing up
a little bit to that in the whirling vortex,
what question do we really want to answer
here, and starting from those ideas again.
There's a really nice FDR overview and some
slides that Chris Genovese has posted that
I used to help summarize some of the results
above.
So moving on to bias from the multiple testing.
The quintessential example of anyone teaching
bias and variability- I know this is the case
in public health and, probably, a lot of areas--
is this four targets here.
And you're shooting arrows at the target.
Upper left, we've got low bias and low variability.
We average out there in the bull's eye, and
they're not very far apart.
Moving to the right, we're still averaging
out near the bullseye, but there's a lot more
spread.
And a single shot may be further away.
Bottom left, we've got high bias and low variability.
We keep hitting the same spot, but we're off
consistently by some amount.
And the last one, we're not close to the bull's
eye, and we're not very consistent- so high
bias, high variability.
So this connection with bias and variability
is an important one I'd like to keep talking
about.
But first, this is The New Yorker cartoon
version of that.
There's something called the Texas Sharpshooter
approach where you shoot the side of the barn
then paint the bull's eye around it.
This is the medieval version where you've
got someone to do the painting for you.
So some bias we live with every day.
So those of you who are parents probably have
used an ear thermometer.
Or those of you who just don't like having
a thermometer under your tongue may have used
an ear thermometer.
They don't give you the same number.
They both measure body temperature, and they're
both pretty reliable.
They have smaller variability.
And you get the similar answers as long as
you use it right, but they're not centered
in the same place.
In this case, there's low variability.
You've got reproduceable bias, but we can
correct for the bias with a simple adjustment.
In the case of the thermometers, we memorize
what normal is on either one.
And then if you take your child's temperature,
you're also trying to remember is this-- do
they seem well enough to go to school or not.
Bias and variability come together.
And there's this bias variability trade-off
in a lot of statistics books.
And one of these is if you're talking about
the mean squared error prediction, how well
are you doing?
One summary of that is taking the expected
value of the difference between your prediction
and the truth, what you're predicting, squaring
that.
That's called the mean square error.
And doing some algebra, you find this is a
sum of two things.
If the variance of your prediction plus the
square of the bias of your prediction, how
far you're off.
So if bias goes down, variance can go up for
the mean squared error can still stay the
same.
So the accuracy of your prediction is a function
of both the variability of your prediction
and the squared bias and your prediction.
This is an old statistical idea, and it carries
a lot of settings.
And sometimes, you can reduce the variance
by incorporating a little bias.
So Tom Lewis has a nice essay on bias isn't
necessarily a bad thing as long as you have
some control over it, if it helps rein things
in.
This is an element of a lot of Bayesian methods
which induce some bias, but they actually
add precision, and they borrow information
across data sets.
I think, last week, Michael Newton's BD2K
seminar in Bayesian statistics gave some overview
of this.
But if you look up borrowing information,
you'll see how a biased estimate can actually
give you some improvement over an unbiased
one.
Let's think of an example of linear regression.
A lot of times when you are taught linear
regression, you're told that ordinary least
squares estimates are unbiased.
And in ordinary least squares, you're trying
to pick some parameter's data to minimize
the difference between the regression model,
the x beta minus the observations y squared.
And it's unbiased.
But there's an important caveat to that.
It's only unbiased if we have all the right
covariates in the model.
And I put this simple regression picture up
here that I made up because when I took a
regression class, they told us how to build
a least square machine.
I thought this was a cool idea.
It would be hard to scale this up, though.
But if I had a board of wood, and I nailed
in nails were all my points were, and I had
a stick, and I had rubber bands from each
point-- and I have to make sure the rubber
bands are going up and down with the y direction.
But you snap it, the stick, the equilibrium
point where all the pressure is on, the stick
will land on the least squares regression
line.
So let's think about that.
All of those points are pulling on it with
the rubber band.
And so it's going to end up in the middle.
And it's trying to have the minimum total
tension in the rubber bands.
Let's suppose we really need X1 and X2.
So rather than just a single line, there's
this plane.
And the way I've tried to draw this is there's
a negative slope going down in the x2 direction
and a negative slope in the y direction, but
it slopes.
You can see we've got clouds of points around
it.
So suppose we really needed X1 and X2 to do
this.
But if we only observe X1-- I'm going to back
up one slide-- it's like we're taking a flashlight
shining it down on the X1 y plane.
All those points are going to put their shadows
there.
These gray lines I have-- the solid grey lines--
are the lines in my plane just to show the
different groups, the different parts of X1
and X2.
But you really wouldn't see that.
And if you fit a regression line-- let's say
it's this dashed line here.
It may be unbiased, but there's an awful lot
of noise around it as opposed to the amount
of noise that would have been around the plane.
So it might be unbiased but noisier.
But suppose we didn't get to see all of the
X2s, and there was some change in whether
they were included or not.
So I'm only including the ones in the circle
now, which means for the low X1s, I only saw
low X1s for the X2s.
So the non-circled ones get left out.
And if you notice the bar for X2 out here
is the higher values of X2.
I've picked low ones.
And for the higher values of X2, I picked
the high X1s.
Now, I would get a line that goes in the completely
other direction.
So there's a sampling bit.
If there are changes in the chance of things
being included, it can bias our results.
And it can do it quite a bit.
So what happened?
It turned out X2 contained important information
we needed to consider.
In this case, it had information about what
values of X1 were included in the dataset
we got to see.
And the result is a biased estimate of the
true association between X1 and y.
So this is one type of bias that can result
in observational studies.
If we don't control for the value of X2, but
it had an influence on what we were seeing,
then our resulting estimates would be changed.
Now this is, sort of, an example of confounding.
Confounding is a big word in epidemiology.
And confounding gets brought up in big data
analysis often.
Rothman and Greenland describe it as a confusion
of effects.
In the example above, X2 was confounding the
effect of X1 because X2 was controlling which
values of X1 we saw.
Now confounding-- and I've written encyclopedia
entries on confounding.
And every time I do, I get a headache because
it's not easy to define mathematically.
There's no single mathematical definition
or statistical definition, so it's hard to
develop some sort of test or solution.
But it is a conceptual mean we all understand.
It's to an effect that would confound the
one we're interested in.
So if we were looking at associations with
smoking and lung cancer, age might be a confounder.
There may be a birth cohort confounding in
terms of level of smoking.
So the concept's familiar.
There's always room for sensitivity analysis
with confounding.
You can try to include potential confounders
and see whether your results change when you
add them or take them out of your analysis.
And I think this is a particularly important
contribution to the subject matter part of
the Venn diagram for data science because
there are often established sets of potential
confounders for particular outcomes.
And ind epidemiology literature, if you don't
control for age and race, the referees are
going to ask you why you didn't do it.
So you could even check and not have it make
a difference and leave it out.
You will still be asked about it because so
many health effects vary with age.
So many health disparities are observed of
different race groups.
And smoking has always had a big influence
too.
So this is-- I'd encourage you to think about
it.
But, like I said, I've been thinking about
it for 30 years, and it still is hard to get
a handle on.
Now I need to click on-- there, we go.
Another example of expression array-- and
this came up in Rafa Irizarry's BD2K webinar,
which is archive.
He was looking at gene expression arrays and
talking about batch effects.
When gene expression arrays first came out,
it was an amazing thing.
He could measure responsiveness in multiple
genes at once.
And so his experiment here, he's discussing--
or the example he's talking about is-- suppose
you're comparing gene expression array results,
and you have some of your gene expressions
from tumor cells, and some of the genes are
from non-tumor cells.
But you sent it to the lab in two batches,
and let's say they ran all the tumor samples
on Friday, then everyone left for the weekend.
They came back and ran the non-tumor cells
on Monday.
And you see a difference in the expression
between the different genes you're investigating.
What does it mean?
Well, we'd like to think it means a tumor
or non-tumor difference, but it may well be
a day of processing difference.
It may take a while to get the lab set up
again on Monday, or we may not have things
turned on and warmed up.
Or-- this is a design issue behind even observational
studies.
So one of the things you would see in the
evolution of publication about microarray
analysis or gene expression analysis was an
introduction of adding replicates and starting
to look for some of these confounders.
So if you're interested in and more of that
example, Rafa Irizarry's BD2K seminar does
a nice job of walking through that and
showing a lot of examples.
The last area I want to talk about is missing
data.
So what if you're missing outcome values for
some predictors?
Or what if you're missing predictor values
for some outcomes?
Should you ignore it?
I mean, what becomes a frequent, if not ubiquitous,
issue in connecting large data sets is that
you won't have all the pieces.
Should you ignore it?
Should you plug in a reasonable number?
Should you just put in the mean and hope for
the best?
These are all things that are done sometimes
and I think that we've all thought about.
If you're missing the outcome, one algorithm
that's seen wide use on the smaller scale--
and we have to see how it scales up-- is something
called the EM algorithm, the Expectation Maximization
algorithm.
So suppose you're missing a few of your outcomes
variables, but you have the Xs.
You have the predictor values in your regression
model.
So I'll show you some graphs of what this
looks like.
The algorithm, or these algorithms, iterate
between filling in the missing information
based on your current analysis-- your currently
fitted model-- and then refilling the model
and updating your estimates, and so on until
this converges.
So in a regression setting, we might have
the following.
Let's say we have the observed dots, but the
two I've circled we didn't really get to see
the y values.
So I know what the x values are.
Those are the dashed lines there, but I don't
know what the y value is.
Now if I knew the right answer, I should get
the gray dashed line.
But if I leave these two out, I get a bias.
I get an orange graphed line.
So the E-step is on the left, and the M-step
is on the right.
The E-step, you would assign the missing values--
the expectation from the orange line.
This is what we think these two y values should
be if the model was right.
Then the M-step is to put those values in
and recalculate the orange lines, so it moves
over.
In this case, it got closer to the gray line.
And then you'd iterate back and forth with
these.
You'd be updating what you think y is an updating
what your estimate is.
And another pretty broad conditions, this
will converge to the right answer.
So again, just the E-step is expected values.
The M-step is refit the model with updated
guesses for missing data, and you repeat til
convergence.
Now I'm sure this has been scaled to big data
and distributed computing.
But trying to take the algorithm and break
it down in a way that could go off of distributed
processors, and so on, it has a lot of validity
and a lot of interest.
Now if the covariates are missing, what do
we do?
Do we ignore them?
We've already seen that ignoring X2 in our
example earlier lead to confounding and bias
because it was important.
Could we impute a value or make a guess?
What if we could guess a lot of values?
Would there would be value in that?
Well, multiple imputation is an area that's
been used a lot in smaller data analysis and
has some similarities to
cross validation.
It gets used a lot in big data analysis.
It's just not-- they're not doing exactly
the same thing.
What multiple imputation does is for every
missing value, you simulate multiple values.
And then-- even doing two or three for each
one rather than just one allows you to estimate
the missing value itself and the variability
in that missing value.
So you're not guessing it perfectly, but you're
going to have to guess it with some variation
and then percolate that variation through
to your model.
So the imputed values inform us on the overall
variability of our estimate or prediction,
and they take into account the extra variability
we've added by putting our imputation in.
So this requires a model for imputation.
How would you impute it?
How often would you impute?
And the Little and Rubin book is really the
standard for both EM algorithm and multiple
imputation.
I also like Schafer's book, even though it's
been out quite a while.
There may be a second edition to this.
And seeing how some of these ideas could be
played out in the big data setting, I think,
would be incredibly valuable.
Just to wrap up, and then we'll leave us some
time for questions, if any have come in.
Multiple testing-- the main issue is if we
check a lot of things, we need to control
for the impact of false positives.
So what do we do about this?
We should always worry about multiple testing.
I mean, I don't say you should not do it,
but you should be somewhat concerned and maybe
feel a little bad about it.
But, you know, the ideas like false discovery
rate and similar summaries are gaining a lot
of ground.
We've got a better understanding of them.
And it involved backing up to the basic ideas
and building something that was more extendable.
And bias-- the issue is the estimates differ
from the true values.
And what we should do, well, of course, we
should worry about that.
We should document and adjust if possible
as my ear and mouth thermometer example.
But also trying to get-- in a more general
sense-- trying to model the observation process,
starting to think about how we see the data
we see-- how that can have an influence on
this.
So I really think that subject matter component
is important in data science.
It's not just a calculation and then hope
the numbers are right.
So I think there's a lot of work to do on
thinking about bias.
And, again, tied into that Bayesian estimation,
it provides a way to borrow information that
may be a little biased, but it may improve
our precision.
With confounding, we've got to factor outside
of our analysis impacting our results.
Again, what we should do is worry.
And epidemiology articles are particularly
good at thinking about ways that the observational
conclusions may be wrong and how to prove
it better.
I think sensitivity analyses are always a
good idea in terms of checking the impact
of things.
Now on a large data setting, we might not
have the flexibility for, say, simulations
that we do on a smaller scale, but we might
want to think about ways to look for evidence.
You know, what wake does confounding leave
in your data as it moves through it?
It's also important to catalogue the common
confounders in a certain area of application.
We shouldn't be doing analyses de novo in
every setting, and we should learn from the
past.
I think this is one of the points that the
Lazer et al. article was making about the
Flu Trends.
It's fine to make mistakes, but we also don't
need to do our analysis completely oblivious
of what people know about this area or about
the data types.
Finally, with missing data, the issue is the
data are not complete.
This is not a surprise to anyone.
But, again, we should worry about it not just
brush it under the rug.
Especially documenting, the reason it's missing--
I gave you an example with my confounder,
where I had missing datas on X2 that impacted
the estimate of X1.
And that's because the probability of being
included was related to the outcome I was
looking at.
You have a lot less bias if that missingness
mechanism is random.
If you have data missing completely at random
or a little more generally missing at random,
it won't impact your results as much.
There are things like the EM algorithm and
imputation, but I do think there's a lot of
work there to think about scaling those up
into more general tools and having them fit
in to the data scientist toolbox.
And model missingness-- I think there's a
lot of room for explaining why the data are
missing.
That may actually be the first round of analysis
you do.
In my example, there was an indication that
the value of X2 had an impact on whether X1
was observed.
And if you can understand then model the missingness,
this might help untangle the effects it has.
So to just bring this all together-- data
and analysis issues that come from statistics
and epidemiology by statistics, like the four
we talked about today, all have deep backgrounds
at standard size analysis, but they may not
scale directly to the big data setting.
And I think this is a very interesting area
for collaborations between the large-scale
data scientist interests and these people
trained in statistics and epidemiology.
So these aren't issues that one can avoid.
So I wasn't being totally facetious about
saying worry about everything.
I think worry is essential to doing good work.
The Bonferroni and false discovery rate example
illustrates how addressing data issues in
a big data setting can require rethinking
even basic assumptions.
It didn't say the assumptions were wrong.
It just said the relevant proportion we were
interested in was different than what the
Bonferroni had been adjusting.
So there's a lot of background within each
of the three or seven or however many elements
of the Venn diagram.
But I think the most interesting research
advances occur in the overlap.
And that's where I think data science will
come into its own.
So I really like the idea of team data science
and having different skill sets available
and has a great framework for addressing this.
I think it's more interesting to have a statistician
and a computer scientist in the room both
thinking about the same problem rather than
having them work separately and then present
their solutions to each other.
So I would say let's go forward and make new
mistakes together.
And I believe we have some time for questions.
Fantastic lecture, Lance.
Thank you so much.
We do want to encourage people to write in
their questions.
And as people are putting fingers to keys,
I had a couple of questions.
And I thought these are, sort of, big questions.
And I wanted to just get your thoughts on
these.
You had mentioned one thing in some of your
introductory remarks in a couple of remarks
you had made.
And one of them involved an interesting term,
which I thought was-- I don't know-- caught
my attention.
That was of data hubris-- big data hubris.
And you can understand that lots of people
think, oh, if we just have more data, the
answers will be in there.
And we've got all these methods and techniques
to go and just ferret them out, and we'll
just know everything.
And the hubris element of that I find to be
somewhat fascinating.
I think one of the more recent examples of
this that everybody's aware of-- and I don't
mean to get political here, but-- was in the
recent US elections, where it was clear that
one candidate, everyone was predicting that
that candidate was totally going to walk away
with the election.
And then, on the given night, everyone was
a little surprised at how that turned out.
And I'm curious if you have any thoughts about
whether or not there was any bias or variance
in the processes that led up to that somewhat
surprising outcome.
Well, I'd say the kind of ubiquity and ease
of doing a survey that may not be a scientific
sample survey-- I think the polls, and so
on, really took a hit.
I don't know if other people are like me,
but I'm getting multiple calls at dinner time
now that are recorded surveys on how's the
government doing.
And in my heart, as a statistician, I want
to supply data.
But in my head, I also realize these are all
paid for by different groups.
And the wording of the questions are looking
one way or the other.
And so I think that it was a lot of-- with
the diversified news media and everything,
they know what will play to their audience.
And so questions were asked in a certain way.
I don't think there was as much pooling of
the information across the survey.
I mean, there's a very complicated setting.
There's a lot written about Facebook and the
kind of divergent-- you have your group of
friends, and you forward articles that tell
you the same thing.
We're all in our own bubbles.
I think FiveThirtyEight tries to do a good
job of that.
But you've got all this information.
FiveThirtyEight worked really well the last
couple of elections because it was based on
polls that had measures of uncertainty.
And that's what it's good at doing, putting
it together.
But if the
questions are leading, your probability and
my probability of participating is not equal
for every poll.
And I am frustrated by that, but I also am
reacting just like a lot of other people are.
I may only be answering polls that cater to
what I hope.
And I think in that setting, a poll doesn't
work anymore.
So there is this idea that having a lot of
data, but finding that it's the people who
responded.
And that's why modeling the missingness is
really important and understanding where it
comes from.
So going back to that data analysis whirling
vortex, knowing what data you would like to
get and how that differs from the data that
you can get or you ultimately get and what
question you did answer with your data,
I think we assumed we we're answering the
question about who's going to win the election.
But we were actually answering questions about
who's ahead in the minds of those who respond
to this particular.
Once we start putting all the caveats in there,
we start realizing we answered a much more
specific question than the general one we
were interested in.
So one of our listeners writes in, and they're
asking about the expectation maximization
methodology and whether or not the iterations
that you use to fill in the missing data--
how often does that lead to a wrong model?
Does that make sense?
And so-
Yeah.
Why not just ignore those points?
You go through this big thing, and it converges
on something, and you think, oh, Eureka!
There's my model.
But, in fact, it's, in fact, wrong.
How often does that happen?
Right, so it has a good-- it has a pretty
general set of regularity conditions, the
conditions under which it does what it's supposed
to do and converges to the right answer.
It won't converge to as precise an answer
than if you had all the data, because there's
some uncertainty in those missing pieces.
But it should move in the right direction.
There's a fair amount of literature on the--
just for lack of a better term, calling it
a small data setting, of its performance and
how well it works.
You know, I think one of the biggest questions
for some of these statistical techniques and
rolling them out to the big data setting is
could you distribute it and put it back together?
So it's like MapReduce, except it's doing
the analysis on that.
So that's how there's-- used to be-- it had
a different name, but Bill Chambers is doing
a lot of this-- of what kind of statistical
algorithms can be broken into pieces that
they can be sent off to different processors
and then recombined in such a way that you
keep the answer?
So I think that's a very active area for work.
It's wide open for good ideas.
And, I think, that's an area where pairing
a statistical researcher or a methodologist
with a computer scientist could lead to some
big improvements in both areas.
And the joint improvement of both areas is
where data science gets better.
Great.
Another question I had was-- I see amongst
a lot of younger investigators, some of the
post-doctoral Fellows that I've encountered,
there seems to be a particular
value put on finding ever more smaller P-values.
And so somebody will go find something that's
1 times 10 to the negative 16th and get very,
very excited, because, oh, it's much better
than 1 times 10 to the negative 4th.
And so they think it's more important.
And they make the classic mistake, I think,
of mistaking statistical significance with
practical and theoretical significance.
They may only be accounting for 3% of the
variance, but is wildly significant because
they've got big data.
What sort of message can we convey to people
to maybe avoid some of the issues that come
up when you fall into that sort of trap, if
that makes sense?
Yeah, I mean, I think the easy trap to fall
in with P-values is the smaller one must be
more significant.
You know, one of the things-- there's been
some push back.
Some journals want except P-values anymore.
And I think part of that is because there's--
I think P-values serve a purpose by themselves,
but I think they're overused and overinterpreted,
and this is one example in which that happens.
You know, even if the null hypothesis is true,
the actual P-value you get should be uniformly
distributed between 0 and 1.
So ranking them if you're not rejecting doesn't
make sense, and then the distribution shifts.
I'm saying a lot of words.
What I think would be helpful is if we start
thinking about measures of association and
then bringing in the subject matter aspect
of the Venn diagram.
Is the difference we saw really meaningful?
Because there can be statistical significance,
but the difference you actually detected was
kind of small.
And I don't like to see these P-value contests
like you said.
I think that's putting too much emphasis on
something that's hard to estimate.
And, to me, a P-value of 10 to the minus 6--
I don't even know what that means, because
I've never really observed too many things
with a million observations to get this one
in a million.
And if you get these really tiny ones, I think
weird things happen.
And that we don't appreciate that even though
it had a small probability, it still could
happen.
Yeah, I agree.
I find that when people in certain areas of
big data research start talking about P-values
that are 10 to the minus 16th, or something,
I mean, they're down in the machine precision
of errors.
You just can't trust anything that gets that
low.
And the emphasis being on the P-value, I think,
is somewhat misguided.
And I'm not quite sure how that happened because
I was always brought up to think, how much
of the variance am i accounting for, for example.
You know, that givers me a sense of how strong
my model is.
And that ends up not being very important
to some people.
Maybe I missed a memo, but it seems that that's
what people-
I think it's an example of data science is
a new field with people coming from other
fields.
And that's why I was talking about the team
data science, because these concepts that
you carry with you are what you trained to
look for.
What was important about doing the analysis?
And having people with different perspectives,
I think, is in a broader image of that.
And so there's people who think all of statistics
is what they get in one class.
Similarly, there's people who think all of
computer science is what they got in one class.
And we really need to recognize that's not
the case.
And it's very hard to be an expert at both
of them.
But you can learn a lot of things from experts
in them if they're getting together and working
together.
So I think data science is a highly collaborative
field.
I like to think of statistics as highly collaborative
but data science, I think, is often even more
so.
And it's a combination of people with different
intuitions, expertise, experience, default
assumptions.
And that's where I think we can sort a lot
of things out with these kind of collaborations
and conversations.
I'm really glad to hear you say that, because
the last question I had was how can we help
universities and university administrators
understand that team data science is important?
It's not just statistics.
It's not just computer science that most universities
already have.
But it's something that's unique and special.
How can we help them to recognize that?
I think it's good to highlight the successes
in places that have-- a lot of universities
develop institutes of data science, for instance.
Some of those institutes are within computer
science, or they're within another field,
but I think the really strongest ones and
the ones that I think are making the biggest
difference will ultimately-- and I hope this
is the case-- continue to make a big difference
will be the ones that have this interdisciplinary
feel.
And I have gone to a lot of statistics conferences
where people say, well, aren't we data scientists?
That was the early conversation.
The conversation I heard last week at a statistics
conference was we're part of an Institute,
and we have a track on statistical methodology
or a track on health analytics because we
work in a lot of health area, we can help
put the algorithms in perspective and what
kind of questions they can answer.
And we establish some-- not standards but
usual ways of doing things.
To me, I think that's a big development because
that would argue against having a center for
data science inside a statistics department
or a center for data science inside a computer
science department without talking to each
other.
So, you know, I think as we see developments
happen that have benefited from the interdisciplinary
collaboration, I think that's where we'll
really-- I hate to wait for that to happen.
But I think that's where the big developments
will be.
And so as those happen-- and also, I am a
little afraid that some of the purely algorithmic
approaches are going to make some big mistakes
somewhere.
And maybe it's not just guessing how many
people had flu last
week.
Maybe it's predicting a drug assignment for
cancer in precision medicine.
If you use a machine learning algorithm that
works really well for getting pretty good
increase in your profit in a business setting,
and you apply that blindly as a black box--
and I don't know if anyone would do that--
but suppose you did to defining that, you
may get 90% of the things right, but you've
got 10% of patients who are getting the wrong
dose.
And that could be fatal.
It could be costly.
So some of this is-- I think statisticians
are inbred worriers because of variance.
And we think about all the kind of errors
we can make.
We give them names-- type 1, type 2 errors.
We need to develop what can go wrong.
And that's where these four topics came up
today.
Well, let me thank you on behalf of all of
our listeners today for your fantastic talk,
Dr. Waller.
Thank you very, very much.
Once again, we'll be having another one of
these next Friday at 9:00 am Pacific and noon
Eastern.
And we look forward to seeing you all again
then.
Thank you again, Dr. Waller.
Thank you very much.